welcome back to the rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode 4. my favorite
episode yet of this series because it
traps us into the middle of a rebel
Mission no one wants us on and makes us
host a space Nazi Senate dinner party we
don't want to host Star Wars you know
some of those other Star Wars content
creators may feel dismayed by the load
numbers covering this show but I can
hear the Reckoning Taps out there the
spark that ignites the flame I have hope
hope that more and more people are gonna
find out how great this show is so the
meantime let's break down this episode
frame by frame everything you missed in
it because you know what these indoor
Easter eggs are a bit harder to spot and
I got you covered and this video is
sponsored by raid Shadow Legends we'll
give you some more info on them in just
a moment Nicholas Patel's opening music
hits way harder for episode 4 with this
intense percussion
[Music]
because now we are off of the planet
ferricks and cassianandor has joined the
Sprint of the Rebellion Lutheran sets
the coordinates for the planet aldani
calculations complete
it's the computer voice of Lutheran's
fonder hallcraft is a voice actor and
sound designer David W Collins who has
worked on a ton of Star Wars titles over
the years but I don't think he's
credited on this much [ __ ] Cassian
says then in a fund the whole craft
flown them never seen one do that yeah
so hyperspace travel requires hyper
drives powered by molecular displacement
not every ship has hyperdrive especially
smaller ones because they're pretty huge
the fact that Lutheran has somehow been
able to install one of these on the
smaller local vessel is likely how this
trickster's been able to travel planet
to planet undetected Lutheran tells
Cassie that there's really no point in
going alone because we're dealing with
the Empire here he was the same rope to
hang you whether it's for a plasma coil
or 20 million credits yes plasma coils
are parts used by the income Corporation
the company that builds x-wings Cassian
speculates who Lutheran is Alliance
except gorilla parties in front one of
them isn't it all the same Alliance of
course approach Rebel Alliance set to
separatist in the Clone Wars era gorilla
and partisan threat referred to song
guerrera's faction of rebels with more
terroristic tactics now no doubt that
you've heard about rage Shadow legends
from us before the new Rockstar's crew
Kink enough of it raid is a console
sized gaming experience that fits in
your pocket but the game itself is huge
there are over 600 Champions blessed
with unique skills to choose from
millions of combinations to battle with
I can't list them all here but what I
can do is tell you who the three most
badass Champions are at the moment
practice the shifter gets up there for
the sake of werewolf Venus followed by
creelo witch arm for the sake of which
arminess and my number one badass
Champion cisia blame tongue the sake of
being a fire demon with a giant sword
this month you can take your badass
Champions into a brutal new dungeon the
iron twins Fortress beat the iron Twins
and you'll be able to awaken your
Champions Awakening lets you choose a
blessing that transforms how you battle
it adds a ton of depth and strategy
giving you even more options for how to
badassly battle your way through raid
also Ultimate Death Knight is finally
here everyone can get him for free just
by logging in all you gotta do is log in
and play raid for seven days between now
and October 27th whether you're new to
raid or a grizzled veteran use the DK
Rises promo code for a bunch of free
items so you can instantly level your
new strongest Champion all the way to
level 50. five star Ascension but if you
are new to trade click the link in the
description or scan the QR code here on
screen and you'll get unique bonuses
worth thirty dollars you'll get a free
epic Champion Aina 200 000 silver one
energy refill and one XP boost and one
ancient Shard and collect all your
goodies just by hitting the treasure
icon right here and these bonuses are
only available for the next 30 days and
only for new players just head to your
inbox to claim everything but first
download raid by clicking the link below
there's never been a better time to get
started casting talks about his
background I thought in Midland when I
was 16 and who did it turn out we were
fighting
ourselves this membon is a bog Planet
originally created for the 1977 Star
Wars film and used in the 1978 novel
Splinter The Mind's Eye by Alan Dean
Foster one of the earliest and best
works of Star Wars extended Universe
fiction minbon was mentioned in Clone
Wars and considered for rogue one before
Jenna replaced it as a setting and
finally showed a live action and solo a
Star Wars story where Han Solo fought in
the Battle of minban as an imperial
infantry Cadet mimban is where Han first
met Chewbacca so could Cassian have met
Han or Chewie on minban maybe but
Lutheran calls out that Cassian was
actually a cook and maybe a deserter you
were on the ground in Melbourne for six
months
it came in as a cook you lived because
you ran Cassie and Lutheran say they
were fighting themselves on mimban
during the Empire The Campaign was
actually waged Against The membonese
Liberation Army who was originally aided
by the Republic clone troopers during
the Clone Wars so similar to United
States war efforts in places like
Afghanistan the enemy are the kind of
Freedom Fighters our side originally
aided against a different enemy so in a
way fighting ourselves or at least
fighting our own weapons and again by
knowing that Cassian was a cook on
mimban Lutheran reveals how much
homework he has done on this guy and how
really that starpath unit was the kind
of test for a new recruit I didn't risk
my ass for the start
I came for you and Luther reveals the
score the quarterly payroll for an
entire Imperial sector a smart plan cut
the Empire's ability to pay their forces
hit him in their wallets onto Coruscant
its cityscape surface lit up from the
space but a closer look at the buildings
show that the urban setting is colder
rare more muted in color tone than when
we saw it in Revenge of the Sith and
recently an Obi-Wan Kenobi flashbacks
dendra Miro approaches the Imperial
Security Bureau the Empire's
intelligence gathering sector major
particles is their Superior played
amazingly by Anton lesser qyburn from
Game of Thrones supervisor Grande
reports with the next quarter's
detention estimates expected to increase
across the ryloth sector any further
erosion in local Authority may require
an increase in our black line budget yes
ryloth is home to the twilik species
including the sindula family and nine
years before this sham cindula plotted
the kill Darth Sidious and Darth Vader
on a planet ryloth and of course failed
this led to an increase in Imperial
presence on rylot that will lead to
Harrison Doula embarking on her Rebel
path and piloting the ghost Rebels
meanwhile regret reports that mining has
resumed on the occupied lands of arvala
six arvala seven is the name of the
desert planet in the same system from
season one of the Mandalorian this is
where denjarin finds grogu from a gang
of meekdos particles stands up and
lectures at the ISB mission statement is
actually wrong security is an illusion
you want security cover Navy we are
Health Care Providers we treat sickness
whether they arise from within or have
come from the outside yes and unless
they're recklessly Zips through all of
his lines Max efficiency as if it's a
sin to waste any time or effort when
you're on the Empire's clock this
comparison to their work is treating
disease recalls the grand inquisitor's
philosophy about the Jedi but the Jedi
code is like an itch he cannot help it
but where is the Grand Inquisitor
simplifies this ill as a compulsion that
must be Stamped Out particles
disturbingly views all descent as a kind
of disorder that's treatable with the
right medicine which forces to ask
what's creepier an extermination in a
Purge or a kind of enslavement in
brainwashing blevin reports the latest
drama from barracks and more Lana one
that we saw in the first three episodes
and mentions the recovered Imperial
starpath unit which freaks out dejramiro
because that's her jurisdiction she's
wondering how did that even get in their
hands project guys asks young about
traffic to the abrian sector proactive
measures uh there's an increase in
construction shipments going to scarif
so I scarif really the closest thing
we've gotten so far to Star Wars major
events continuity scare if you should
know is where the Empire moved
construction of the Death Star from
Geonosis four years prior under the
supervision of director Orson Crane and
while I don't need cameos from Vader or
Palpatine or even Tarkin on this series
I'd love me some Ben Mendelson critic
showing up please onto the planet aldani
this is actually shot in the real world
Scottish Highlands the gorgeous Green
Hills near the crookin dam and its power
station it's an actual Dam you can go
visit it Cassian chooses the name Clem
as his Alias which is the name of Marvis
partner and we think cassian's foster
dad who was hung on the street in ferrix
Lutheran gives Cassian a down payment
it's a quarter segment Luke kyber
skystone the ancient world celebrates
the uprising against the right cutting
Invaders so caviar crystals are of
course the energy crystals from ilum and
other places that are used to power
lightsabers Balu then says this is a
kuati Signet huati refers to an ancient
Merchant family from kuat a core world
run by a matriarchal society they kind
of refer to themselves by the collective
pronoun of we much of what we know about
has until now been considered legends
non-canonical from titles like the Old
Republic stories ever since the 2015
Disney buyout but lately Star Wars
titles have begun to recanonize certain
Legends elements this really started
with thrawn and Star Wars Rebels one of
the coolest characters from The Legend
stories and it's continued on in the
Star Wars Disney Plus shows with things
like The Witches of dathomir mentioned
in Boba Fett similarly the rakatans were
created for the Knights of the Old
Republic game and were later established
as the original creators of hyperdrive
Technology they were an ancient race of
conquerors who were wiped out by the
Republic over the ages so with this one
little Crystal Andor just brought back
in a Star Wars canon in huge sections of
Star Wars lore if you like Tony Gilroy
probably just asked Pablo Hidalgo to
write a story behind this Crystal and
Pablo was like uh yes please luthan
tells Belle sartha leader this mission
that Clem is joining the team whether
she likes it or not and he starts out
nice but I love how he loses his
patience with her we'll take him in and
lie about how it's come to pass you plug
him in as a replacement for anyone who
goes down along the way the next three
days if for any reason look at me
you want it to lead
this is what he comes to Lutheran is
clearly desperate for this mission to
succeed and for casting to be a part of
it they just do such a good job in this
episode establishing the stakes of this
Mission as a pinkly arranged timing
sensitive plot with a lot of moving
Parts as if there's a number of
off-screen buffens who died to give us
this information in the window it's
about to close now I noticed Cassian has
now shaved his beard using a blade but
leaving a sexy length of stubble
remember since his mug shot was clean
shaven I assume he's just worried about
the Recent Looks he got on barracks and
I'm sure it has nothing to do with the
actor needing different facial hair when
they shot the Scotland stuff Imperial
inspectors have scored away the primor
folks and one has to clear their trash
including a carton of what I assume
contains some blue Ramen into a bin
seriously what is wrong with these
people for leaving their workspace is a
mess like that blevin reprimands Cyril
Karn Linus mosque and chief Hein now
before we mention how Carn tailored his
uniform you can see how there's some
orange trim around the edge that aren't
on the uniforms other two and standing
next to high and you can see how Heinz
company badge is sewn on crooked blevin
tells Karn you've rung the final Bell on
corporate Independence as of this
morning the Milana system is under
permanent Imperial Authority rung the
final Bell especially cutting as it
recalls a Time Grappler Bell on ferricks
the temporal epicenter of the town in
the root of how they all clanged on
metal to communicate their Grassroots
Reckoning Vel talks about Lutheran he is
something we will never discuss when we
get to Camp we're going to tell them
this was my idea and we've been planning
it all the while we never mention him
now I assume this is a form of
deniability among the rebel factions in
order to protect Lutheran in case any of
the rebels get captured or if they flip
but this also feels a little personal
between Belle and luthin like they might
have a history maybe she is his daughter
she has the same hair color and the same
Frosty blue eyes after all patrolling
Tie fighters Buzz past
[Music]
their iconic engine scream is damping at
first but then Roars as they cross over
the ridge I love the sound design and
everything Luke is filmed dendra reads
about the star path unit in the report
and sign retrieved a sealed Imperial ns9
star path unit from the site
that is our books from state of God has
to be yeah Lutheran said the star path
unit had been on stearguard so there is
more to the story of how it was stolen
and who loot then stearguard contact
might be despite the muted color tone of
all this Detra keeps a small bonsai-like
tree in her office maybe a sign that
there might be some goodness in her that
we have yet to see Luther opens a hidden
compartment on a ship where he changes
into his wardrobe including a wig some
beautiful purple clothes and rings on
each finger Stone Skarsgard just takes
his great beat to emotionally reset
himself Tony Gilroy said Stellan told
him it was all in the hands and you can
see that specific hand gesture that he
mentioned in the interview here which he
drops and magically his character melts
away Belle's team includes Charis nemec
Alex lother from the Shut Up and Dance
episode of black mirror in the end of
the world on Netflix and arvel skein
actor imamas Bachrach Richie from the
bear skin catches nimiks sleeping you
ride with Mossy garbish
Sol Guerrera all the sleep on watch
they're going to put your head on a pike
for a laugh yeah you mentioned saw
Guerrera there the leader of the Rebel
partisans our favorite from Rogue one
who
won huge episode the other
s on the terraman barcona and cinta Kaz
they're posing as Shepherds and they
keep a pen of sheep with horns curved
like bantha horns and several of these
horns per sheep exhausted it count all
the Sheep stuff did Mayan make you yawn
I bet I've had some Beyond didn't you
Cyril Khan lands at a Spaceport where
the announcer says it for the PA
tell Gordo travel is a shipping company
from the Star Wars role-playing game
Bosnian Prime of course the core world
that will later become the capital for
the new Republic until the first order
makes it go boom boom in the force
awakens plexus was a sector also
mentioned the role-playing games and
euphoris major was a planet mentioned in
a junior novel companion book to Star
Wars Rebels so Cyril's Homeworld must be
one of these three Cyril takes the
elevator down since the Spaceport in the
Metro would be on the top levels of the
cityscape and the living quarters would
be lower and lower further down but it
also just mirrors how this guy is pretty
much Rock Bottom in his career his
mother Edie slaps him and takes him in
she's played by actress Catherine Hunter
big from the Order of the Phoenix and
played the witches in the tragedy
Macbeth last year Senator Mon mothma
visits Lutheran storage and avivo Riley
returning from Rogue one after first
playing the role in a revenge of the
leaded scene of course the character
first played by Carolyn Blackiston in
Return of the Jedi this story is an
intricate revolving door this whole area
is just bright and strolled by these
rich women making it seem like
coruscants Rodeo Drive Lutheran tells
man makma free your mind Senator this is
a place where time stands still it's
hard being it's around founded with this
much history and not be humbled by the
insignificance of our daily anxiety we
often refer to the gallery as corazon's
unofficial Temple of patience so yeah in
addition to being a front for Rebel
activity this also might be
might be holding onto the past in an era
when the Empire would want to tear down
all other vestiges of culture as they
did with the Jedi Temple now in this
shop is a Kell door breathing apparatus
much like the one worn by Jedi Master
PLO [ __ ] who knows maybe the same one
make me wonder Luther are you really
Gathering trophies from dead Jedi are
you really gonna go to that extreme to
keep up the facade I think people
believe you already you're good you're
good I also assume his karate signic
hyper Crystal might have been something
from this collection he also singles out
an udupon monk Kajol being the planet
from Revenge of the Sith where the grand
Inquisitor originated from there's also
some armor that might be old Mandalorian
bescar armor I don't know best car would
be pretty hard to come by there's also a
twilik kalakori it's a traditional totem
carried by All twilik Families there are
some stone tablets that have the same
symbols as the Keystone that Ezra got
from the loath wolves and Rebels there's
also some gungan Shields you know like
the ones that jar jar and the other
gungins use in the Battle of Naboo and
Phantom Menace and then I think that is
the helmet of the Starkiller armor from
Force Unleashed balutan takes her in the
back to talk about another artifact
two-faced Divinity sun goddess and a
serpent from the Overworld sharing the
same mouth Yes this Stone Art reflects
both Lutheran and Monmouth as people
both of them are two based figures in a
way one Persona in the sun one in the
Underworld but both having to speak out
of the same mouth come on mothma says I
found someone I think can help me
someone who
to bring into the circle no she may be
referring to bail Organa but I would
think Bill might already be part of the
center circle could be Bale's daughter
Leia who would be currently working as
an apprentice Senator under man's
mentorship I don't know maybe Monmouth
wants to use the girl as a money mule a
way for her to move some credits back
and forth now the seventh member of the
aldani Rebel team arrives via Speeder
Bike this is Lieutenant Gorn an imperial
Defector there were men on the inside he
mentions an imperial engineer arriving
from Coruscant who might be Galen urso
maybe the spirit where Galen is being
moved from Coruscant to ianu and his
first death star super laser research
mon matma's husband perin added some
familiar names to the dinner party guest
list
from the vizier's private chamber yeah
ours dangor was first mentioned the
Tarkin novel and was implied to be one
of the goofy-headed men from Palpatine's
Entourage and returned the Jedi Sly more
is that creepy looking bald and bar and
female a de Palpatine first seen an
attack of the Clones and often at his
side and that chick is a force Adept you
do not want to be sitting across
somewhere at a dinner table trying to
hide stuff these are main political foes
these people are fun who are they are
they fun
I wish you'd find some Gorman guests for
tonight and see how amused they are your
fun friends just cut off their shipping
lanes yesterday do you know how many
will start off ah Gorman's Gormans are
the impressed people who will fall
victim to an imperial Massacre three
years from now and speaking out on it
will actually make Monument might have
to leave the Senate turn fugitive and
publicly head to Rebellion back of
maldoni a model shows the dam in the
valley when the Empire jammed up the
sacred River we learned that nemec
actually made this by hand overseas not
to scale who is this guy Doc Brown take
some credit excuse the crudity of this
model I didn't have time to build it to
scale it opinion Gorn describes this
astronomical event that they're going to
use as cover once every three years the
odanis gathered in this Valley for a
Celestial event but like a curtain being
pulled across the sky until the eye the
window to the Galaxy forms over the
horizon a curtain pulled over the sky
sounds like a classic George Lucas white
bed it doesn't it but it's so me
so mint as their escape path as if the
mystics who were driven from these lands
can finally have a victory over the
empire in addition to the mission having
practical Stakes that really just gives
our mission deeper spiritual Stakes
Dedra and blevin take their case to
particles it is my feeling that this is
part of an ongoing effort to steal
proprietary Imperial equipment in
anticipation of an organized Rebellion I
have three previous case files on my
desk that begin to suggest a pattern yes
she's probably onto something but for
now Poltergeist misses her concerns yet
compliments her detention numbers from
Sev talk Sev talk is a mid-rimp planet
mentioned in the Darth Plagueis novel
Cassian is handed a Garrison map and an
aldani phrase book with an orabish
alphabet and corresponding all Donny
letters which she's gotta learn by
morning now since Cassian spoke qinari
for the first decade of his life do we
really know if he can read orabish that
well let alone translate to aldani I
mean something tells me that Lutheran
totally lied about those three languages
that Cassie could speak I don't know
maybe I'm just reading into that Leah
Michelle look on his face follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow me Rockstar subscribe are some
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]